Every guy wants to be a great husband.
If you don't, then there's probably
something wrong with you and you will
never have a great marriage.
So how do you do it?
How do you have a great marriage where
your wife treats you like a king?
Well, she will automatically do
it if you treat her like a queen.
Do you?
The Bible says in 1 Peter 3:7:
[1 Peter 3:7]
Now, there are a lot of things that we can talk
about when it comes to being a great husband, but
I want to focus in on five important things and
the first thing is: Treat your wife like a queen.
It is so simple and yet so many
people do not realize this.
So many men, that your actions create the
reactions from your wife and you can test it.
For example, if you want her to make
you coffee in bed, start doing it first.
All you got to do is treat her
the way you want her to treat you.
If you want more attention from her but
don't give her the attention she needs,
what do you think is going to happen ?
If you want her to make you delicious
food sometimes but you never make food for
her or take care of your household chores,
then what do you think is going to happen?
If you live with her in an understanding
way knowing what she needs - fulfilling
it - then the chances are extremely high
that she will also fulfill your needs.
But the husband is the leader
so you need to act first.
I'll say it again - treat her like a
queen and she will treat you like a king.
Wash her feet.
When was the last time you
actually did something for your wife that she
really wanted or would like or is marriage for
you just about you... a selfish life?
The Bible says that the husband is
the leader of the home just like
Jesus is the head of the church.
What kind of leader was Jesus?
He led by example, by serving.
He gave his life for the church and
he washed the feet of the disciples.
[John 13:12-15]
Now listen to this, very important part.
[John 13:16]
If you have to wash other people's feet - think
about them as more important than yourself.
Then how more important is it
when it comes to your wife?
The wife that God gave you to wash her feet.
Because remember, you are now one flesh.
[Mark 10:7-9]
If you lead your wife the way Jesus Christ leads
the church, then your wife will gladly follow you.
Not because she feels that
she has to, but out of love.
You're not the boss, you're the leader.
And you need to follow the example of Jesus.
So you need to do what...?
You need to serve your wife.
Number three: Let go of your pride.
It's one of the biggest problems that
marriages experience is pride, especially
when it comes to the man in the house.
When he is arrogant and full of pride.
Full of that self that Jesus says that
you have to deny yourself, pick
up your cross and follow Jesus.
That is a true man.
A selfish man will never
have a great marriage.
Listen to this verse.
[Philippians 2:3-4]
Now this does not mean that
you should let your wife walk
all over you, because you are the leader.
You lead by example, by following Christ.
By setting the example.
It means that you lead
her according to God's Word.
That's how you set the example.
According to this verse, you put yourself
in her shoes and understand what she needs
from you and then give it to her and a lot of
times that requires you to sacrifice your own
desires and to put her needs above your own.
And if you start to do that you will see that
she is starting to do the same and it creates
this amazing loving open caring relationship,
where you both are humble and willing to
support each other in whatever you need.
Number four: Never put your wife above God.
Always put God first in your life, above
yourself, above your wife, above your kids,
above everything else in your life.
If you do it, God will be with you.
He will bless you in everything that you do.
He will take care of everything.
[Romans 8:28]
Especially when it comes to the big decisions.
Actually, all the decisions of your life.
But especially decisions regarding your marriage,
your finances, your children,
career, your relationships.
In all of it, you need to put
God first and follow His will.
And then everything will
work out the way it should.
[Matthew 6:31-32]
These things - about clothing, drinking, food.
These things are just examples of the
things that you worry about usually.
God says that you don't need to worry about it.
He's your father and he will give you what you
need if you put Him first.
Listen to the next verse.
[Matthew 6:33]
That's the condition for the
promise that now follows.
[Matthew 6:33]
Of course, you need to include
your wife in all your decisions.
Talk to her, ask her advice, because her role
as the wife is to support you, right? But your
wife is not smarter than God.
You are not smarter than God.
So you talk about these things.
Communication.
So you know all your options.
You bring it to the feet of Jesus Christ.
You pray about it and you ask Him,
alright, how do you want me to handle this?
How do you want my wife to handle this?
How do you want us to act in this situation?
[Proverbs 3:5-6]
It doesn't say in all your
ways acknowledge yourself or
your wife or what everybody else tells you.
It says in all your ways, acknowledge Him.
You as the leader of the home.
You have the responsibility to
follow God's will.
And then it says:
[Proverbs 3:6]
That's the blessing.
If your wife says one thing and God says another
thing then you should not listen to your wife.
You should listen to God.
For example, if your wife says let's go and buy
this car and you pray and know it is not God's
will to buy it, then don't do it.
She makes mistakes.
You? You also make mistakes.
But God never makes any mistakes and
there's already so much in God's Word that He has
already revealed to us, how He wants us to live.
And so if we follow it - if we walk
in His will - He will bless us.
For example, the Bible says you
have to discipline your kids.
If your wife doesn't want you to discipline your
kids and you listen to your wife and you don't
do it, God's not going to bless you.
The consequences of not obeying God.
Because that is what sin is
... it is not obeying God.
Sin in its essence is not following God's Word.
And the consequences of that is always bad.
So what do you think is going to happen if you
don't discipline your kids in love and truth?
Then your children will not respect you
and will grow up into selfish adults who
think they always get what they want, when they
want, no matter what they do, even if it's bad.
Evil.
There's no consequences.
And they always get away with it.
And doing that actually helps their
sinful flesh to grow even stronger.
And that's how criminals are created.
Over the last few decades, parents have
been disciplining their kids less and less.
They're not listening to the Word of God.
And what is the result?
You can see this new generation
compared to our generation.
They have a lot less respect for their parents.
They're very different and very selfish.
And that is actually also a sign that
we're slowly moving towards the end times.
[2 Timothy 3-5]
Put God first in your life.
Discipline your children with love.
If you do that while they're young, they
won't stray from it when they are older.
Folly is in the heart of a child, but
if you discipline him, it takes it out.
Put God first in your marriage.
In everything that you do.
It is God's Word that says that you have to
love your wife not when you feel like it.
It's a command.
It's an act of your will, not just a feeling.
The feeling, a lot of people focus on
that kind of love, is the eros love.
Sexual love.
The attraction love.
There's also agape love, which is the
unconditional love that God has for us.
That's the love that you also
have to have for your wife,
to love her even when you don't feel like it.
[Ephesians 5:25]
True peace and joy come only from God.
Not from your wife.
Your wife helps, but that kind of peace that
surpasses all understanding and that joy,
even in trials and tribulations
- that can come only from God.
And you need to understand this because
there are a lot of couples out there,
they blame their partners because
they don't have a good life,
instead of taking responsibility for
your own life and looking to Christ.
Your wife is not responsible
for how you feel all the time.
She does help you to have a great life,
but it is your responsibility and you need
to look to God to get that fire within you.
[John 14:27]
You always get your purpose, that fire,
purpose, peace, fulfillment ... everything
that you need, you can get from Jesus Christ.
Don't look to it at your wife all the time and
expect her to give you everything the whole time.
You're going to burn her out.
You're going to be too clingy
and she will get tired of it.
I'll say it again.
True peace and joy
come only from God and not from temporary
worldly things including people and your wife.
[Philippians 4:6]
In other words, lean on God.
Have a good relationship with God.
Talk to him all the time.
This is where you get the peace
that surpasses all understanding.
Which it says in the next verse.
[Phillippians 4:7]
You know, a lot of men complain about their wives.
They say things like she should be less grumpy.
She should be more thankful
to me for working hard.
She should put on the clothes that I want her to.
She should stop nagging me all the time.
She makes being a mom her main personality
trait, and she never gives me attention anymore.
She should learn how to be
more hospitable to my family.
She should do more in the house.
She-she-she.
It's always easier to look at
others and blame others, right?
While some of those things might be true and
she might improve on it based on God's Word.
Did it ever occur to you that maybe some of those
things that she's doing is a result a reaction?
Reactions, maybe more, because of YOUR actions?
How YOU are in the house.
She might be tired of giving and giving and
giving and not really receiving anything from you.
The things that she really needs.
And she's just human and humans are not perfect.
Are you giving your wife what
she needs according to the Bible?
[1 Peter 3:7]
This is so serious to God that He's
basically saying that if you don't
treat your wife in an understanding way, the
way you should according to the Word of God,
then your prayers will be hindered.
You might be busy with religious things.
You might even preach in the church.
You might do your Bible studies and do all
these religious things, while they actually mean
nothing, because your prayers that's hindered.
Because back home you and your
relationship with your wife is not good.
You're not treating her the way you should.
Some of you are too harsh with the wife
that God gave you.
This is serious.
[Colossians 3:19]
Guys, we need to understand this.
If we don't treat our wives right, if we
don't lead them according to God's Word, then our
wives, they have full right to hold us accountable
because they need to support us, right?
And that means when we stray from the path, they
always put God first, right? When we stray they
have the right to say, hey, come back on the path.
That means they don't have to listen to you if you
say things that are not in line with scripture.
But if you do say things to her - if you
do lead according to scripture - then she
needs to listen to you because then
she's just obeying scripture, right?
[Ephesians 5:22]
As to the Lord.
This is amazing, right?
Because this is an example of how our relationship
is - true believers with Christ, right?
The church.
And Christ, how He came to serve.
How He loves us.
And so this is as Paul
puts it - it is profound.
You get it?
It means that you never lead your
wife - your household - in the flesh.
You as John, Peter, David - you
don't lead it as you want to.
You lead your wife and your
children as Christ leads the church.
So don't lead them in the soul level - your own
intellect - your own emotions - your own will.
We're going to do this.
No, you lead them through
the Spirit as Christ leads the church in truth.
In love, in, oh there's so much beauty in that
kind of relationship, that kind of leadership.
And that includes forgiving each other as well.
As Christ forgave you, you
also need to forgive your wife.
[Ephesians 4:32]
Marriage is awesome.
One of the best things
you will ever experience in this life.
If God is in the center, and if all
these four types of love is in it as well.
Storge - family love, philia - friendship
love, eros- sexual attraction love, and
agape - unconditional sacrificial love.
A marriage is the only relationship
with these four types of love in it.
And agape is the most important because
that is unconditional sacrificial love.
You sacrifice your own life and you put
your wife - her needs - above your own.
That's the kind of love where
you have an amazing marriage.
This is where you choose to always
love your wife no matter what,
because it is not a feeling, it is
an act of your will, and you have no
excuses because if you are a true reborn
Christian, you have God's Spirit in you.
That means you can produce the fruit
of the Spirit and one of it is love.
[Galatians 5:22]
Now, go and produce this fruit in your marriage.
Love your wife the right way.
Lead your wife the right way.
And be a great husband.
And if you haven't subscribed
yet, then please subscribe.
We bring out videos every week and there
might be some ones here that you might like.
And I'll see you there.
And always remember this: life is short,
so don't waste yours.
Bye guys.